yeah you know what welcome to this video
playing in addition was a city guy who
is that no name okay let's hope he plays
a little bit according to the name
everybody wants a Point C in there come
on so looks like a specially cough
coming up or no the classical society
okay yeah I'm going for the rouser this
is one of the things that have not yet
studied so possibly you shaky-shaky a
proposition here let's see what he does
this I know this is a this is a valuable
line and for now is one thing I'll be
should be too I think okay let's play
Bishop t2 i remember some very old cup
of games that that went like that oh wow
interesting let's not a pawn structure
that had anticipated anyway but he's
playing this quite confidently so well I
have 95 so I think there is no
particular reason not to play this go
into the eighth I guess I don't see any
other decent square okay so i can just
check but I felt like this should be a
little bit no idea i can actually take
the five hmm I never step out a stupid
move I wanted to play Bishop f6 now
intermediate move but he will take on a
tool that's a little bit a little bit
awkward and Pontius was not my intention
but that was not my intention hmm not
good well I don't think this is a bad
position for me but that definitely not
what I intended to play so how do i play
here I would like to provoke some sort
of weakness on the King side I wonder
like a queen to f5 not sure about this
but
I don't see anything fundamentally wrong
with it like your technical shot or
anything and Bishop d3 might provoke
some sort of reaction
well that's surprising
the surprising thing is that it doesn't
threaten anything I mean I can actually
even take play h5 but he would have
quiero que it Bishop d3 is also possible
i would not so good okay um I think I'm
just going back leaving him with this
potential hook on age six to open up the
position I actually think this is a good
position for me I see very little
counter play my king is they're very
safe and I have some ideas here age five
and stuff yeah so here well I can I can
play g 5y can take it both makes some
sense
g5 is very slow the slow though let's
take it
so I can play Bishop h3 here or you
should play quick this is one thing okay
Jade or what's the deal yeah Bishop h3
looking lips Bishop e6 stuff like that
it's um what is on the agenda for this
in Bishop f5
interesting with ya bish should be six
was my original idea i canti can't cover
this it's not completely convincing
really this one frightening just to take
the vision the night now one minute
something that's a not so great iam
[Music]
would reply is playing well
at least I don't really see anything
brilliant for me and he's quick about it
important check otherwise I think I'm
just material down some I'm playing this
disturbance smooth I know he cannot
really take it was a bit too Wow time
morning sucking the exchange why I don't
know what's that necessary he wants to
somehow bring me into an ending don't
know Trading Queens his king is still
somewhat unsaved
okay I'm doing stupid things yeah
completely unnecessary also did not have
to give them the stuff getting a bit
nervous IAM for no reason whatsoever
[Music]
check I could have had it much easier
life here in this position much much
easier
that's not easy em absolutely not check
one nice thing is that he is not playing
well and not particularly quickly it's
actually check for check aah chak chak
chak chak chak you put your brief
lickfest check check I took the worth it
it's fun telling you yeah okay that
doesn't make any sense but that's what
this time control is like that's what it
is I don't take it all to examining
after the games it's stupid yeah this
was a very very bad oops no one up that
one very bad loss and completely
pointless oops come on pretty pointless
because white had a pretty good position
yeah something like this is pretty nice
for me and then any sacrifice the
exchange completely unchecked I really
like this after that why just wins with
I didn't didn't play it in any kind of I
mean does this doesn't my plate didn't
make any sense simply um yeah I I kind
of I had anticipated I had not
anticipated before because it's also not
a good move but I was basically thinking
I played King a one no matter wat to
play c4 c5 and ok and then you played
this one where I can do whatever hoop g5
or what just or c4 I mean just I can
also just cover this like it's just an
exchange down for nothing and here it
gets yeah yeah I got completely
irritated check yeah this is again of
course winning but am NOT quick not
quick at all can I saw that I'm not just
winning the bishop here but I wanted an
easier check easier moves let's say
check the problem can't always myself
I'm always into chicks maybe I should
have traded here and okay to against 10
that won't work may I should just win
this on position and nothing else okay
thanks for watching